this feels like an obvious thing to say
but tanks are expensive both to buy and
to fuel if you want to train someone to
drive one it'd be great if they could
learn the basics on a simulator first so
in the 1970s the Swiss Army had the idea
to design and build tank simulators but
this was well before computer generated
images they couldn't create a virtual
world so instead they built a wonderful
example of 70s analog technology The
View screen in that box is connected to
a real camera and a real miniature
landscape through there in the past
thousands and thousands of tank drivers
trained on machines like that there's
now only one simulator left in the world
and it's in the Swiss Military Museum
about an hour north of Zurich and
tourists can try it they're existed in
the past 12 simulators for different
type of Tanks it's very accurate for
teaching the basics and the teaching
where to go with the hand and with the
feet put that over your head and then
because in in a normal tank it's too
loud with the motor noises we have a
special microphone that goes around
exactly okay so this goes on light
this oh lies okay that's interesting yep
okay that's it
okay looks good
let's let's drive a tank yeah I wish you
a good drive thank you
wow okay all right so
um start the Hydraulics yeah oh boy okay
sounds good now you can start the main
motor start the main motor
[Music]
ah okay
should probably be on the right hand
side of the road I guess
um you can drive in the middle
what are they gonna do all right yeah
sure
you can go in the fourth gear fourth
gear cool
okay get it said a little bit more
forward so I gotta hit the back of my
head when that happens yeah that's the
only one of the type 68 tank that's
remaining and we managed to get it
running here it took roughly about one
and a half two years we had to really go
into it from ground up it was very
difficult not for everything but mostly
for the electrical and electronic parts
because it's all Tech it's not like you
can go to any supermarket and buy it if
gear skin ah we need to sit oh we're
gonna do one this feels very fast down
all of a sudden
there is something about the analog
miniature model like nobody close up to
its short but when the trees are in the
distance this is really convincing there
is a memory function on the computer
module which uh on base of this x and y
axis says you're here you're on gravel
you're on snow you're a normal Earth
you're on road and something like that
if you're driving to a tree the the feet
where the camera sits on just moves up
and it's like you're you're having a
panoramic right above our model with a
helicopter okay we can go out
I am good yeah
we'll start being right from the camera
to put where you're driving on like it's
kind of a metal slide if that's it like
moves a tiny bit or for instance if
there's like some contact with it and it
moves for instance I need to go up to go
over that the it will notice that and
signalize the cabin that you're moving
over something the camera's original the
foot is original the whole model is
original everything except for the
computer part is original but it was too
old and you don't find parts easily for
that so we have to rebuild it on the
Raspberry Pi you can go into fourth gear
again if you're comfortable yeah
every time
we should say of course this is this is
a bit of fun for tourists now but this
was a serious training game like if
you're actually having to drive around
and take in Wartime it's a very very
different experience yes it is
really dangerous what you do here is
again
is like a game
this shop is not a game
thank you very much we're welcome how do
I get out of here